hey guys it's justine and today we have
the brand new samsung devices in hand
this is like my favorite time of the
year because i am so obsessed with
foldable devices so we have the brand
new samsung galaxy z flip 4 and the
samsung galaxy z fold four let's open
these up and check them out we're gonna
start with the flip because that's my
favorite device of all time yes the fold
is more of a premium device but this
flip the form factor is just my absolute
favorite so we're gonna start with that
man i'm so excited i'm so excited oh
okay so this is like a pastel kind of
like a light little violet color like a
lavender that looks great
the purple's beautiful i also like that
it's kind of a like matte finish as
opposed to super shiny because this
already you can tell way less
fingerprints so here's the galaxy z flip
it has a new slimmer hinge a larger 3
700 milliamp hour battery and you can
quick charge it up to 50 in 30 minutes
it also has wireless power share the 6.7
inch display has a 120 hertz adaptable
refresh rate and it's supposedly 45
percent stronger with a new ultra thin
glass it has a snapdragon 8 plus gen 1
processor ipx8 water resistance an
upgraded main camera that is 65 brighter
with improved stabilization and tracking
you can configure the storage from 128
up to 512 gigs with 8 gigs of ram the
starting price is 9.99 and it comes in
borah purple graphite and two new colors
pink gold and blue you'll also be able
to further customize up to 75 different
color combinations with their bespoke
editions let's open up the fold
so this is the gray green
let's take a look at this color
so this is actually
really cool because i'm not a huge fan
of the color green
but this to me
if this was a color test i wouldn't tell
you that this was green maybe i'm
colorblind is this how i'm finding out
because this looks kind of blue to me
i'm going to need a set of jenna eyes
yeah i do actually really like the color
what do you guys think what color do you
think this is is this gray green i mean
that's what they're saying it is it's a
great color though there's just
something so cool about the samsung fold
like it just feels like a very premium
device the first thing that i am
noticing is how not noticeable the
camera is under the display it's kind of
crazy because it's like yeah you can see
it but it blends in so well the new
galaxy z fold is lighter with a new
wider aspect ratio it's made of upgraded
materials with a more durable fold the
main screen panel is 45 stronger it has
smaller bezels and a slimmer hinge you
can upgrade the storage from 256 up to
one terabyte with 128 gigs of ram a
snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 chipset 4 400
milliamp hour battery and fast wireless
charging up to 50 in 30 minutes there's
three cameras 12 megapixel ultra wide
upgraded 50 megapixel wide and 10
megapixel telephoto the new camera will
get you 30x space zoom with a 23
brighter sensor so you'll have clearer
photos at night there's an additional 10
megapixel front-facing camera underneath
the display it comes in three colors
phantom gray gray green and beige the
display camera better blends in with
content so it'll be way less noticeable
than before starting price for the fold
is 17.99 so now that i have these both
unboxed i'm gonna go set them up and
i'll be
right back
[Music]
so excited it is all set up i've got
that both turned on i've got some
content loaded ready to go i also have
the fingerprint sensors activated both
of the fingerprint sensors are here on
the side buttons like usual i really
wish that apple would just put a
fingerprint sensor on the power button
like they did in the ipad air so clearly
it's possible so here's the displays on
the fold here's the front cover display
now obviously if you want to use this
just with the front cover like you have
that ability you can basically use your
entire phone just like this here's last
year's video with the flip and the fold
three i was actually in hawaii i wish
that i was there right now so here's
what the cover screen looks like if
you're watching a youtube video and it's
cool because you can kind of pinch in to
zoom in so this is what it would look
like normally if you want to zoom in to
have a full screen view you can do that
as well now as soon as i open this they
adapt to whatever type of content you're
watching or whatever it is that you're
doing and there's what it looks like if
it's all zoomed in on a full screen
you'll see right here is their new
taskbar so this will give you easy quick
access to all of your apps anything that
you have open and also the controls to
get back to your home main screen this
flip is still
just my absolute favorite i love being
able to have this little cover screen so
you can have all kinds of notifications
you can also now take portrait photos
using these front cameras and you'll be
able to use the cover display to kind of
be able to see what you're taking a
photo of which is super helpful it's
great because you don't even have to
flip open your phone so i could just
wave
and it's taking the picture
okay jenna's gonna put her face in there
there it is she's waving on flex mode it
kind of turns your flip into a little
tiny laptop and it is just too cute so
let's show you kind of what youtube
looks like if you're watching some
content on here so i can continue to
scroll down here and i can watch my
content up here so you can basically
still control this so if i want to fast
forward
go backwards now these phones have been
out for several years it's great because
this has given developers and other app
creators enough time to kind of figure
out a way to make their apps work and be
optimized with these flippable and
foldable devices now one of the things
that i think a lot of people always ask
about is the crease
the hinge what does it look like on the
screen and it's hard to explain because
when you actually are using this phone
you kind of just forget that it's there
you don't really see it you can kind of
feel it it's something that just kind of
goes away you don't really realize that
it's there it's kind of like the notch
on the macbooks you just sort of forget
that it's there although i think that
this crease may be a little less
noticeable than the notch you can also
flip your phone this way as well if you
want to view your content and that'll
give you a full screen view you could
also zoom in and zoom out on your
content to get your preferred view i
think it did a great job with the under
display camera i was really excited to
see what the next iteration of that
would look like you guys can see right
here this is where the camera is and you
can see it's kind of like a little
more pixelated so like we know it's
there but if you're sort of looking
around your screen you're not actually
going to really notice that at all
unless you're looking for it so that was
just the first look at the new samsung
galaxy flip 4 and the fold 4. i am so
excited to test these devices out
further so look for a full video on both
of these very very soon let me know some
things that you guys would like to see
me test out in those future videos and i
look forward to reading them in the
comments below i would also love to know
what's your favorite color of the new
devices see you guys in the next video
be sure to subscribe hit the bell to be
notified when i post new videos and i
will see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]